OK.
Let's go back to the phones at six one seven
eight three zero forty seven feet.
See what people want to talk about.
We'll go to our caller from the six two six
area code.
Who's calling today from six to six?
Hi, David, my name's Steve.
Hey, Steve, what's going on?
Not much appreciate your show, so thanks for
what you do.
My my question centers more around.
So I'm a very big progressive and I was a
huge Bernie supporter.
But at the end of the day, I'm sorry, at the
end of the day, like you, I recognized the
moment that we're in with Trump in office
and we can't just take a chance.
But it occurs to me that given everything
that's happened with Corona virus and of course,
with a boy with a lot of action and the boy
on their.
I'm sorry, I'm trying to get this car was
could have been in retrospect or even now
since we're doing this new election with Biden
as bite in the right candidate overall for
the moment, because he's seems more normal.
Yeah.
Okay.
So is he the right or committed it?
Is he an acceptable candidate?
Is he the best candidate?
Are all different questions, right?
So like you as a progressive myself, I'm too
brk to Biden's left.
I would like to have someone more progressive.
That's question one.
Is Biden the ideal candidate from a political
standpoint?
Would all else being equal without being ages?
Do I think that we need to replace an old
white guy for lack of a better term with an
older white guy?
I don't know.
I mean, it's like, OK, you know, I'm not I
don't I'm not a just or it's not really a
question of of that.
But it's it's more just like, is this the
direction we should be going at this point
or do we need something that we might call
a kind of reinvigorated young leadership?
Maybe.
But is Biden an acceptable choice given the
circumstances?
Yes.
I mean, he's acceptable enough and that he's
better than Trump, and that's who I'm going
to vote for.
Right.
No, no, I understand that, and I fully agree,
I, I guess more, you know, as you cover your
covering polls from Arkansas.
He seems to be down only by two by the arrows.
And you see him very competitive in states
that are more like Bernie Sanders raises.
I don't invision him being competitive in
Arkansas and I don't think biting will win
Arkansas.
But all these polls as he goes, double digit
leads for Trump.
I don't know that if Bernie were and of course,
we saw the way we can't count or chickens
before they hatch, rather.
But I guess I don't imagine Bernie doing as
well in the polls if he were the nominee,
even though he's my preferred guy.
It's I don't know the answer to that.
I mean, it's you know what?
It's one of these counterfactuals that is
indefeasible in the sense that what can we
say?
You know, back in 2016, you had a big crowd
of people saying Bernie would have defeated
Trump if it had been Bernie instead of Hillary.
Now, I mean, you know, you have people saying
Bernie would be doing better against Trump.
But at the same time, Bernie did very poorly
against Biden.
But even early on, Bernie was down by two
million votes.
I know it ended up being much more, but that
was after Bernie dropped out.
So I don't I don't know that we gain much
from the analysis because we can't possibly
know the answer.
Yeah, no, I know, fair enough.
No, that makes sense.
That was something I was thinking about.
But by the way, before the show, I appreciate
the work you set.
Your voice sounds just like MSNBC.
Steve Kornacki.
This is not Steve Kornacki, right?
No, no, no, no.
Absolutely not.
All right.
Very good.
OK, Steve, thank you so much for the call.
I appreciate.
Did you have a good day?
OK.
Take care.